thanks for joining hey what's up guys
thank you for joining the stream and
joining me on this this epic adventure
no pun intended but yeah so starting a
new program in this case Unreal Engine
can be very scary very daunting and I
want to walk you guys through the
process of getting started in this
program like how do I even download this
program where do i download it what does
it look like when I when I hop in the
goal of this is to just get you guys
started I've been I've been working on
in an unreal for the last I don't know
two weeks so I just want to share what
I've learned in those two weeks mainly
that getting the program downloaded and
getting the mega scans assets imported
into your scene and then I'll just share
some stuff that I've learned so far with
you guys like some of the lighting and
the atmosphere and the fog and whatnot
but honestly guys I think unreal is the
future it is just incredible the fact
that it's free and all the mega scans
assets that come with it are free and
the stuff you can get from this like let
me just show you guys like what my goal
is at least and it's cool here I saw
this yesterday but it's on this weekly
spotlight this is absolutely incredible
this is all unreal running in real time
and it looks pretty darn photo-real to
me and with the sound design on it's
just incredible but this is the kind of
stuff like if you can do this in real
time this is definitely where the future
is I think you're gonna see the film
industry and the game industry kind of
blend together you know you you see them
using this technology with the
mandalorian and I think you're gonna see
that a lot more right because they're
using this as like a photo real
background and a backdrop for the Star
Wars show but this is just this video
right here I saw this again I saw this
yesterday I think it's a beautiful
example of what you can do in unreal and
the fact that all this is running and
time is crazy and it's like I mean you
guys know I used cinema 4d
I use octane and that's its own thing
certainly but when you show me these
images here and you say you can do this
in real time and get these results I'm
like okay I got to figure that out
because I feel like my job as a VFX
artist and I just realized dang it my
frickin head is blocking the whole thing
that's all good let's see let's see
where we at boom here we go so you know
my job as a VFX artist is to stay on top
of the technology and stay on top of
educating myself I don't want to get
left behind and the more advanced the
technology becomes the quicker it will
be there the easier it'll be to be left
behind in all of this stuff and I
certainly don't want that so when I see
stuff like this when I see that Unreal 5
demonstration with like the rocks coming
down and the beautiful landscape and
like the girl going through and then she
busts out the wingsuit at the end that
whole demo if you guys hadn't seen that
absolutely incredible I might as well
show you
so you know this this is what really
blew my mind was this Unreal 5 demo and
boy absolutely incredible all running in
real time they can change the lighting
in real time and when I saw this I was
like oh I have to learn it if I don't
know this I'm gonna be in trouble
because it is the future so I think I've
gone on enough about in trowing Unreal
Engine so Before we jump in I just want
to talk to you guys about today's
sponsor and it is Skillshare so let me
find this tab here boom so if you guys
don't know Skillshare is an online
community for creatives such as yourself
who are looking to up their game in as
many ways as possible it's set for any
schedule any skill type if you can think
of it you can learn it on Skillshare
it's actually really really cool
the classes are bite-sized and set for
you know basically anyone to learn
whatever they want if you're trying to
do photography the effects you know
Photoshop if you're trying to learn how
to cook if you're trying to learn how to
do your taxes you can learn it all here
on Skillshare so since we're talking
about Unreal Engine today I want to talk
to you guys about what kind of courses
they have with Unreal so the first one
here is actually I mean these are all
really awesome tutorials we got Adam
Zollinger here and he's talking you guys
through how he set up his architectural
visible visualization or arc viz scene
here and you can see that it's a five
hour course and though they do have
quick bite size classes they also have
you know chunky courses like this too
but you can see here on the right it's
all broken down and some you know pretty
reasonable amounts of time here so this
is kind of what you'd create with this
there's also the absolute beginners
guide to Unreal Engine and I've talked
about this one in the past but you know
this is a lot more applicable now
because we are talking about unreal and
this is another you know three hours 30
minutes but
looking down to these bite-sized courses
here and at this it deals with
everything and it'll get you guys up and
running and the last one obviously you
guys know that Unreal Engine will you
may you may not it's used to create
video games right so you can make your
own game inside of Unreal Engine and
this course breaks that down for you so
how to create your own game and again
this is an 11 hour course which i think
is awesome but again it's broken down
into these bite-size little chunks so as
a Skillshare member you guys get access
to regularly updated premium content all
the time for less than ten bucks a month
for an annual subscription and to the
first thousand people who click the link
in the description you guys get to three
months of Skillshare premium on myself
so go ahead and click the link let's get
learning
you got your Unreal tutorials you got
your whole courses right so let's just
jump into today's episode guys Unreal
Engine so what do you do where do you go
how do you get it okay
just google this thing okay epic games
launcher it's also in the description of
this video I'm gonna click the very
first link epic games launcher you're
gonna go ahead and download the epic
games launcher it's free alright and
this is what you are presented with this
is kind of like your hub your home base
when it comes to Unreal Engine ok
let's actually just go to the home tab
come on home tab here we go and you got
a whole bunch of news and stuff it
recently believe Unreal Engine or Unreal
Engine is owned by Epic Games
alright hence the epic games launcher
they recently acquired quick cyl which
is the company who makes all the mega
scans assets so they're working together
which is awesome but yeah so this is all
the news and stuff and if we go to store
they have a lot of free video games you
can also buy some games - you got
Borderlands 3 you know all this good
stuff and then we have library and
library is basically all the games that
you have installed and you got your
friends and then down here is the Unreal
Engine tab and that is what we're here
for
okay so now you're presented with kind
of a new screen and this is the main
screen this is where this is basically
what I'll see every time I open this
thing and again you have all of this
news kind of tailored to developers and
people who are using Unreal Engine and
that's where I pulled that memories of
Australia video and there's all a bunch
of cool highlight and spotlight stuff to
show off the power of this program so
across the top we have a bunch of tabs
there's a learn tab and this is where
you can find a bunch of cool tutorials
and stuff they have documentation
that'll take you to let's just click
this
so the documentation if we go to what is
it getting started maybe it was Unreal
Engine you can look up anything you want
right in here and there's a bunch of
resources too for learning this program
it's very deep it's a very very deep
program so I always find that giving
myself a goal like oh I want to recreate
one of my photos or I just want to learn
about texturing or I just want to learn
about you know using a virtual camera
give yourself a goal and and you know
look up tutorials for that goal
specifically because if you just try and
learn everything it's gonna be too much
I promise but let's go back to the to
the launcher the epic games launcher we
got more online training we got a
community there's just a bunch of cool
little thumbnails here for different
tutorials and whatnot you have your
marketplace now the marketplace is a
spot for you guys to download assets and
whatnot so you can actually pay money to
download different assets different
scenes fully built out levels but they
also have free stuff they have a lot of
free stuff this is free for the month
right so I got this one and I got this
one because I definitely want to create
that those like photo real cinematic
landscapes that's my goal with this so
that's kind of the path I'm going down
with unreal but yeah you can download a
bunch of free assets here and you can
actually search for free permanently
free and there's just a ton of stuff for
you guys to get into here and start
downloading like the list just goes on
and on and on so going across the top we
got library and this is where this is
like your project files and stuff so up
here we have engine versions and you can
click this to install a new version of
unreal I think the latest is 4.25 point
104 point okay so that's an older
version we don't need that so definitely
install this is where you want to
install it okay
is the engine bird
let's make sure you have the latest one
down here is my projects I only have one
I'm trying to recreate one of my photos
it's been very difficult because there's
a lot to learn but that's okay I just
want to get you guys up and running and
then you can look up all the different
tutorials for the stuff that you guys
want to learn on your own and I've also
posted some of my favorite tutorials in
the description below as well and then
below my projects we have vault okay and
this is where all of your assets are
gonna be like that you've downloaded
from the market place so like those
mountains right here the Dead Hills
landscape or the spring landscape you
guys can't see it but like you got
substance designer you know just
different assets different little
project assets that you can bring into
your scene you'll add it to your project
and it'll load in to unreal and then
finally there's twin motion I honestly
don't know what this is but it looks
like it's some sort of real time
architectural visualization alright
that's a whole thing no idea let's go
back to library so are you guys
following so far you got your epic games
launcher it's free all you gotta do is
google it click the first link download
it and then I just presented this showed
you guys you want to go to the unreal
tab go to library now if you go to
settings down here the bottom left you
can check some boxes here because mine
didn't look like a tutorial that I
followed and I think it was because I
had hide game library checked so it made
it look it made it look a little
different like this I was like where's
the other stuff you know where's the
store and everything so that's just an
example right there so let's let's
launch unreal right top right launch
Unreal Engine let's go for it let's dive
in
so you guys might be installing it right
now you might already have it installed
but don't worry you know if you're
installing it will be in here for a
little bit so you can catch up guys
doing good so far yeah oh winbush
everyone say hey to winbush he is
another cinema 4d unreal artist very
very very talented and he's been helping
me out with unreal and learning it as
well so everyone say hey to winbush
check out his videos he's got some
really good tutorials I've been
following them I'm learning I'm go I'm
on the I'm on the path here okay so you
are prompted here with with this dialog
box it's asking you to open up a new
project file or use one of these
templates let's just jump into games I'm
gonna start fresh with you guys we'll go
next and then these these are more so
the templates right so you have a first
person template you can get a third
person template they got vehicles they
got other vehicles they got top-down
these are all for games so I'm gonna
just do like the first person template
here and we'll hit next and it's asking
me some stuff I think by default this is
all fine ray-tracing is disabled I
hadn't messed with that yet so I'm not
gonna get into that but as asking you
where you want all of your project files
stored so just make sure you give it a
nice chunky place on your computer that
has enough space to hold a bunch of
different files and mega scans assets
and whatnot so I'm just going to name
this stream and let's create this
project
all right here we go telling you guys
this is the future this is the future I
want to make this as easy as possible on
you guys to show you it's not that scary
to jump into this thing okay
because how valuable are you gonna be as
an artist in say one year when you're
ahead of the game and no one knows
Unreal Engine but you've been working at
it for a year once a week for 52 weeks
yeah we got to grow our value we gotta
stay on top of the industry here okay so
I'm in here I know if you if you
right-click and then use your WASD your
Waze these you can move around and fly
around the scene so I'm holding down
right click and I'm just moving around
and I always I always think of it like
this
anytime you start something new in this
case Unreal Engine you're crawling
through the program you're trying to
crawl you can't even you can't even
crawl you're just stuck in fetal
position trying to maneuver around the
program but eventually you can start
crawling and once you start crawling you
can get up and you can start walking and
then you'll start running through the
program and then you'll start jumping
and doing you know like free running
around parkour and around and then
you'll be flying around the program and
when you can fly around the program I
think like you're you're you're on the
path to mastery so right now I'm
crawling
I am crawling around this program but
that's ok that's how it all starts again
hold right click use your WASD keys to
move around I know that Q goes down and
E goes up if the come if the cameras
going too fast for you guys you can go
to the top right here camera speed and
just change this and it'll slow it down
a little bit to really like lock things
into view ok what else let's just talk
about what the heck all this stuff is so
on the left if you guys are used to
cinema 4d you have your primitives
they're all up at the top here
that's kind of over on the left here and
you can search different things like
lights right you can have a directional
light you can get a point light
you got your cinematic cameras in here
visual effects
I've only messed with like one or two of
these things you have geometry you can
just click and drag boom it'll pop it
right in and you're presented with the
gizmo you know you can move this around
that's doing this weird ghost thing
let's undo that let's just let's go up
to basic and let's drop in a sphere or
something and when you drop in the
sphere you got these dialog on the right
and you can just click this and zero it
out hit tab to see here are these things
out and I know that if you bring this up
and you hit end it'll land on the ground
so the end key not the end key the end
key boom and it'll snap on the ground so
yeah we have all of the stuff we can
bring into our scene on the left you can
search all this stuff these are all
called actors they're things that move
that can move around your scene I
believe they're all things that can come
into the scene so if your camera actor
your cube actor your floor actor your
lighting actors now down here we have
all of our our attributes and materials
and stuff now let me move my head over
so you guys can see this so if we go to
content if we click this little content
box you have your starter content folder
and in your starter content folder you
have a bunch of different things that
will you know get you guys up and
running there's textures there's
materials blueprints are like blueprints
would be similar to like in cinema 4d if
you set up like an expresso kind of
chain or like a node system in expresso
and it does a certain task that's kind
of what a blueprint is as far as I'm
concerned so like
blueprint ceiling light what is this
it's upside-down but it's like a couple
things parented together that perform a
task so I'm hitting spacebar to cycle
between these gizmos here and I'll just
rotate this up and by default it's on a
snapping system it's on a snapping grid
which is really nice and then to get it
to smack down we'll hit end and it'll
sit right on the ground right there and
this might be flickering I don't know
yet
I can't tell so yeah all all of the
stuff that you're gonna be importing
like textures and materials that's all
gonna be down here
now when you let's say you click on this
cube or the sphere just like in cinema
4d you have your attributes manager you
have your details tab and that's gonna
have all of the stuff that goes along
with this sphere get out your new
plugins alright with this sphere it's
all gonna be in this little box here
this dialogue box you start with your
transform it looks like it's referencing
the mesh and then it has materials let's
go starter content
let's go materials and let's just throw
on some random I don't know stone cobble
something and I'm just dragging and
dropping and we can get close to this
and see you know you surely that is a
cobblestone texture let's drop it on the
ground and see what happens it's huge
it's absolutely massive well that's
weird yeah it's absolutely massive so
I'm wondering maybe if we double-click
this material it's gonna open up this
little material dialog box here this
material window very similar to octane
you know when you're in node view and if
we pop this open full screen we can kind
of orbit around this and oh my goodness
Oh
yes that's a material I might just have
to close this immediately whoo
that is intense
Wow yeah so I want to I want to scale it
down I think there's like a tiling
option somewhere but I do not know where
it is we're already in too deep
all right we just have this massive
thing look how about ground grass it's
huge and in time I'll figure out how to
scale that down it's okay but you guys
get the idea we can drag-and-drop stuff
on here I'm just ctrl Z to undo let's
get like a wood material on here
that's awesome
so anything else yeah up here and then
the top right yeah you basically have
like your object window so you have all
the stuff in your scene laid out here
you can use the search bar to search
anything you want but let's go ahead and
start fresh let's start as fresh as
possible and we'll go let's see let's go
file new level default level we'll save
it and we'll start in a default blank
slate scene here and you can actually
hover over the ground and you can hit
play and you're in your playing your
game you can test it out you can jump
and you can sprint and you can hit
escape to hop out of that okay everyone
following along so far is it where's the
beginner stuff don't worry don't worry
the beginner stuff guys is downloading
the program that if you just go to the
epic games launcher and you download
Unreal Engine
that's the beginner stuff that's it all
right so Unreal Engine we'll go to
library engine versions make sure you
get the
latest version you install it and you've
launched it in the top right up here and
you just pop into a game first-person
default scene here and this is as as new
as it gets here this is as basic as it
gets
right here this is done for me we have a
couple things in our scene if I turn off
everything we're in pitch black so let's
go through each one of the things that
make up what you're seeing right here
okay very simple let's keep it simple
so we have a floor it's on the ground
here and this is all in by default I
didn't add anything now you can click on
the floor and you can press spacebar to
cycle between your gizmos and you can
move it around okay you can rotate your
floor
you can scale your floor up you know
just like your your basic 3d modeling
software or your your your like blender
or your c4d okay and we have our
attributes for the floor on the bottom
right like we talked about the scale of
it the rotation what material is on it
and lots of other stuff but we're not
gonna talk about that so next we have
there's a little player start icon in
the player start icon if I click on this
you can see it situated 112 I don't know
inches centimeters random points above
our floor okay and this is where when
you hit play you'll hop in at this point
so I think if I'm correct I can be back
here I can hit play and I'll still pop
in in the middle of the scene that's
what the players start icon is okay next
we have a light source so let's just
grab a sphere place it in the middle of
our scene I'm gonna move it up and then
hit the end key and it's going to fall
on the ground okay so it looks like our
floor is
sitting above the ground as well so I'm
just gonna use the grid snap and get it
sitting oh if you had F that will snap
your orientation to why is this fear Oh
cuz it's not a sphere let me delete that
and grab an actual sphere there we go
let's move it up hit the end key and
it's gonna sit on the ground let me
scale this thing up so I'm hitting
spacebar gonna cycle through and I'm
just gonna let's actually go down to the
bottom right in our attributes and scale
this thing up let's go five five five
across-the-board it's a little big let's
maybe just try two and we'll bring it
we'll bring this sphere up and then hit
the end key and it's gonna sit right on
the ground again I'm holding right-click
and I'm using WASD to maneuver around Q
and E bring you up and down alright so
next we have oh yeah I didn't go over
the directional light so yeah we have
our light source and that's basically
the Sun okay it's pointing in that
direction it's up there somewhere we
can't see it cuz when I have a sky but
you can change the intensity of it right
you can change the color of it you can
change the angle it looks like if I
cycle to the rotation gizmo I can move
the Sun around like this pretty basic if
you're coming from cinema 4d or blender
right pretty basic stuff now next we
have by default this default scene comes
in with a skylight and the skylight is
your ambient light I'm pretty sure if I
come in here and I turn off the skylight
it's not doing much
but maybe it'll do something if I
something else first so let's take a
look at the sky sphere the sky sphere is
the beautiful clouds you're seeing here
and if I click on the sky sphere you
actually have some options you have your
Sun brightness you have your cloud speed
how fast the clouds move really really
cool
cloud opacity and then I think there's
stars here you can crank up the stars
but they only come out at night so you
have to you have to take your light
source and get it to a point where maybe
it's the sky sphere and you have to
rotate the sky sphere or maybe it is the
light source and I'm not sure why the
scene isn't updating but again I'm new
to this I don't I don't have all the
answers I'm just trying to get you guys
started so that's that's the sky sphere
that's actually getting you that nice
cloud sky going there and the sky light
is still I think you need to rebuild the
lighting as far as I'm concerned and
rebuild the lighting basically kind of
brings things up-to-date it's like if
you were in cinema 4d and you refreshed
your your scene in octane I think that's
kind of what that is so let's try it
let's click this little drop down and
we'll build lighting only and it's gonna
do its thing and usually this takes a
long time if you have a lot of stuff in
your scene building will take a minute
so you can see it down here thinking and
our scene was subtly updated next
there's a spherical reflection capture
and I think this is allowing things to
reflect your environment that's what the
spherical reflection capture is and then
we have atmospheric fog
and it's very subtle but it's up there
the atmospheric fog now since we're on
the topic of fog you guys know I like my
fog that's one thing that I looked into
one of the first things I looked into
when messing around with unreal now if
you hit the G key it's gonna hide all
your stuff you can also hit f11 and hop
into full-screen mode so let's go f11 to
go back into this main mode here and
let's find should be it's exponential
height fog I think its volumes and let's
type it in exponential height fog okay
so let's just drag that into the scene
and you can see automatically things
have changed if we click on the
exponential height fog we can take the
fog density let's just take it to 2 and
you have real-time fog that's so cool I
love this so much now I think you can
make it volumetric simply by clicking
the volumetric box so I'm going to
scroll down and under volumetric fog you
can click that and this is actually how
fog really works I was watching a
tutorial that's linked below he was
saying how we get used to this look but
technically this isn't accurate this
isn't right you want to check that
volumetric box and this is like true fog
how it would actually work now it's
really dense
we should be getting volumetric let's
see yeah you can see that you can see
the volumetric ray of the fog kind of
shining around this thing and my
goodness Gilbert dude it's a little
nicer
I love how you guys are dropping all
these tips for me this is great I have
so much to learn okay so when Bush says
you know quick tip make your light
movable and all your lighting will be
real-time dynamic no need to bake your
lighting thank you in Bush always
appreciate the tips so light source
scroll to the top movable boom so now
the light source is movable and now it's
all real-time it looks like we got a
sunlight coming from this side over here
look at those volumetric rays look at
that that's so nice if we go back to the
exponential height fog you can you know
you can change the color of it and you
change it to like an orange or something
and let's go down here let's take the
scattering distribution I think let's
try that at 2:00 and that's really gonna
scatter that light like crazy and I
think you can mess with the bloom and
stuff I'm not quite sure where that is
it might be in like camera settings or
something but it's all in that fog
tutorial that I've linked for you guys
let's take the scattering distribution
back to like one and then let's take our
fog density to one
and then we'll take our light source and
let's actually bring it down it's it's
up there let's just bring it back up
that's awesome
okay so that's that's a very basic fog
setup I just want to let you guys know
the exponential height fog is kind of
what you want when you're trying to get
fog and you want to just up the fog
density let me go like five and you make
it crazy super foggy and then just
scroll down and check that volumetric
fog box so G is asking will the
real-time rendering beat pre-rendered
anytime I don't know it sounds like
that'd be impossible
like if you're putting more time into a
render I think by default it's gonna be
better right but maybe we're getting
into a future where they're
indistinguishable from each other which
is pretty crazy and I mean dude you get
you guys saw that uh that Australia like
demo this one right here I hadn't read
up on this but I'm willing to bet it's
real time like this this stuff is crazy
you know because I've seen you guys have
seen like the rebirth thing right quick
soul rebirth this this this came out
like last year maybe a year year and a
half ago and this this was like the
first thing that I saw with unreal and
how how photorealist uh from getting how
cinematic this can get because I mean as
a director I want to be able to tell
stories in cool places and if I can
create them from home then that's a
bonus obviously I'd still like to go to
that place I love traveling but
to be able to create like this little
reason I got into 3d is I wanted to
create anything I wanted anything you
want if you can think of it you can
create it you can make it look legit if
you know technically how to do it so as
long as I keep training and keep
learning the program then I will soon be
unstoppable let's talk about how to get
these like rock assets like this right
here into your scene okay and it's very
very easy you'll have to download a
program called quick soul bridge or mega
scans but it's just bridge ok that's all
I know by the company quitzel so I'm
gonna open this quick sabrage yep and
you guys have seen me use this before
when I'm streaming cinema 4d let's go
ahead and move my head back over here
alright Quicksilver edge is incredible
because these assets are all incredible
they're photo real and this image I know
for a fact was created in Unreal Engine
I watched the whole tutorial on the
whole breakdown on this but yeah you can
scroll through here and get these assets
these photo real assets with bridge and
what bridge does is it'll take the
assets and it'll move them into your
scene
it works with cinema 4d it works with
blender it works with 3ds max it works
with Maya it also works with Unreal
Engine and is free with Unreal Engine
now this is a service this uh the the
mega scans service is roughly twenty
bucks a month for the cheapest the
cheapest option but for unreal it comes
free and there is just so much stuff in
here it's so cool yeah you can go to
collections and you can find they have
tutorials just community but if you go
home 3d assets let's just pull some
rocks or something let's go to rock and
we'll go to assembly and there's this
massive quarry outcrop let's download it
so download settings okay we want 8k
resolution we want let's see
unreal for material preset unreal for
mesh format FBX is fine and these are
all level of detail LOD alright so we'll
get all those levels of detail we don't
need anything else really
and let's download it so that's gonna do
its thing now there is if you guys
notice here in my unreal there's a mega
scans button right here mega scans link
with bridge ok click that gives you some
options on bringing stuff in this is all
kind of just set the default for me but
this is how you know it's working this
is how you know you got mega scans
hooked up you'll see the button and to
do that basically if you go back to
bridge when it comes to the export
settings once this is done you guys will
see here okay we got export settings now
that it is on our computer ok we'll go
to export settings and we can export
we've downloaded the original 8k but we
can export it in 2k or 4k so we've got
our 8k texture format jpg that's totally
fine FBX format is fine now we'll go
with level of detail 0 that's the
highest amount of detail right so we're
gonna use that and there should be right
here for me I'm already hooked up but
there should be a button right here that
says like download plugin for unreal
you'll click that it'll start doing the
thing and basically you'll close unreal
you'll reopen it and you should have
this mega scans button right here okay
so in bridge once you get to the export
settings when you have a material or
asset clicked you'll have this option we
want to export to unreal engine we want
engine version the latest one right and
then you're telling it where these
assets are going ok and I'll export this
up here it's thinking it's exporting and
exported successfully now for me it
takes a minute
for these assets to pop into my my scene
here or my level and unreal you can see
right here importing 0% that's gonna
take a second so we'll let that go and
if you guys have any questions at this
moment I'm here so ask away all right
Gavin thanks for the compliment
appreciate you okay
lucky so if I make a small video game
for my end project of third year of
faculty would that would be a nice start
as a question regarding I hopped into a
half to the middle of a question yes
there is a there is a higher quality
than LOD zero there's a the base mesh or
like the the original high poly model
but I don't think we need to do that
right now
winbush thank you for stopping by much
appreciated man it's an honor to have
you here on the stream yeah definitely
getting into unreal where do I think
pyro and dynamics are going well I don't
know anything about power dynamics in
unreal but I did actually come across
this program called ember gen and it's
like real time pyro and simulant like
different simulations smoke and fire and
stuff so check out ember gen if you guys
are looking for real-time results for
that cast of David why am i working at
unreal just for the real-time renders or
visuals is there a bigger plan good
question
mm-hm so I'm working in unreal because I
think it is the future I think you're
gonna see the game industry and the film
industry blend together I think you're
gonna see more films created inside of
Unreal Engine I'm a VFX artist and I
don't want to get lost I don't want to
get stuck behind you know the most
up-to-date programs and techniques I
have like my job is to be knowledgeable
with those things right
so it'd be dumb for me to just say oh
this new up-and-coming software that's
totally crushing it right now and is
free to ignore it would would be
irresponsible so I'm trying to get on
top of that game as fast as possible so
I have that knowledge to better myself
in the future it's also a way for me to
save time right the real-time rendering
absolutely the photo real renders
absolutely that's what I want and then
maybe in the future maybe I'll make a
game you know maybe I'll make some cool
cinematic game or something so I think
if you guys are trying to get into this
industry at all it would be very wise of
you to start learning unreal and that's
that's the whole point of this stream
right here is to get you guys up and
running so let's clear this close this
dialog box we're back in and let's turn
off this fog for a second and let's get
rid of this sphere okay so if we go to
the content browser right here i'ma hit
content and this kind of brings us back
to our root folder structure so we see
here we there's a mega scans folder now
someone double-click that 3d assets
quarry outcrop that's what we downloaded
okay and right here is the asset I'll
click and drag it out into our scene and
now we have this incredibly detailed
rock structure here and it's all running
in real time let me see let me download
a surface that will kind
blend in with this rock so I'm gonna go
back to bridge and maybe we download
like it's cool here cuz you can actually
see the scale of this so there's a
person and then there's the scale but we
can take like limestone rocks or maybe
these ones yeah let's try these and
let's download this and then I'll use
this as our floor right AAA 206 official
welcome welcome to the stream we are
just opening up Unreal Engine and
getting getting some cool assets loaded
in to unreal
that's all we're here to do today is I
just kind of want to demystify this
program and show you guys that it's
accessible and possible for you to get
into all right so this limestone rock is
done right let's go 200 here's that high
poly source check box right here high
poly source which is even more intense
but we're good for now export settings
yep all going to the right place and
we'll export it's thinking and finally
it's going to be successful exported
successfully let's go back to unreal and
we'll let this load in and then we'll
populate the ground a little bit will
change the lighting will add that fog
back in and that's basically as far as
uh is I'm gonna take this today because
I have a lot I have a whole lot to learn
again you guys want to give yourself a
goal right now my goal with Unreal is to
I'll show you guys here real quick I
want to recreate one of my photos
specifically this photo right here this
is a film shot that I took in
Newfoundland Canada right in st. John's
Newfoundland and it's super foggy and
it's wet and cold and windy and I'm just
trying to recreate this inside of of
unreal and I'll actually show you how
far I've got okay once we drop in these
rocks and stuff but this one I'm talking
about you give yourself a goal and
Google the the tutorials that you need
to reach this goal so like how do I
scatter grass across the ground how do i
download the mega scans assets but I
already got you guys on that how do I
create a water shader how do I import
FBX is from cinema 4d into unreal it's
actually very simple you just export FBX
from cinema 4d and import right into
into the program this import button
right here will just do just that
okay so that's loading in it's loading
in all of these level of details and you
can actually fade between the level of
details so when you get real close it'll
be the level of detail zero but when you
go way back here
it'll be like level of detail five or
something you know
okay so let's load in this rock asset
here and I'm going to scale this up
let's see let's just scale this up and
move it around holding alt and that's
going to duplicate and I'm just gonna
kind of orbit this and we'll set up like
a nice little ground here holding alt
once again I'll rotate this a little bit
and you can see like the camera is kind
of crazy so you can go up here to the
top right and just bring the camera down
one and that's really gonna get you
locked in okay so we just have like a
basic kind of setup here how do we make
a camera and change the focal length
okay so what I've experienced or what
I've figured out here is in cinematic
you have a cine camera actor and that's
basically your cinema camera I'm gonna
drag and drop that in and you get a
little preview you can right click the
cine camera actor and go to pilot or hit
ctrl shift P alright we all know we
gotta try and learn our shortcuts so
let's try it ctrl shift P didn't work
control let's maybe try it again ctrl
shift P I think we're okay I think we
got it
or am i the skies for your network I
can't really tell ya I am this guy's
fear no I don't want to be that let's be
the the camera so let's select the
camera ctrl shift P why it's not working
I don't know I'll right-click and I'll
pilot it okay that's the point and I'm
using e to kind of come up out of the
dirt here and I'm holding right click
and maneuvering around using WASD
alright so remember we click the camera
up here in the top right and we're
presented with all of our options of
that camera here on the bottom right so
let's see if we can go focal length
let's try 24 okay and then if you guys
notice there's this auto exposure going
on if I look up at the sky and then down
to the ground you can see how it gets
brighter and darker and there's like
there's an auto exposure element going
on here and we don't want that you know
you definitely go to manual settings
when doing your thing inside of unreal
you want to have full control over it
come on Gilbert
it's flopping Oh thing buddy I'm trying
to learn Unreal Engine as well I think
you can do it this guy's a little terror
you're just getting into everything okay
so auto-exposure
a couple ways to do that you can go to
lit and go to uncheck game settings and
I think you can just kind of move this
around to adjust your exposure there's
also a way Oh level of detail um no we
don't want that I think you uncheck game
settings and you can do it that way you
can also do it by using a post process
volume and this is gonna give you a
bunch of different it's like in cinema
4d inside of octane it's the camera
imager checkbox and you have all the
like camera settings that's kind of what
this post prospect process volume is now
it is a volume and it's presented as
like a little box so you want to scroll
down with it selected there's a little
checkbox for infinite extent and that's
going to make sure that any anything we
change inside of this box happens to the
entire world versus just inside of the
box I know that you can use this kind of
stuff for like if you go underwater you
can use a post-process volume to add
some blur to the water and like you know
change the color and the tint of
everything so it's stuff like that but
we want it global right so we'll hit
that checkbox the infinite extent and
then let's see we want to adjust the
exposure so we'll go to exposure and min
and Max brightness will check both of
those and we'll just hit one for both
and that's gonna make sure that we don't
have any auto exposure going on
so that's set nicely okay
what next
let's get that exponential fog back in
and let's orbit our Sun around the light
source okay
and we can kind of get it shining down
on our scene
man that is awesome
and why it's shining through here I
don't know but we can go full screen
mode and look through our camera and
there's got to be a way to autofocus
this thing so with the camera selected
cinema camera actor camera options
that's the camera I'm not really sure
where it is lens lens settings I don't
know I don't know how to show my fps in
this per the question here in the live
chat but this is this is about as far as
I've gotten
you know importing those mega scans
assets adding some fog getting the light
going man I really want to figure out
the focus do you guys have an autofocus
solve here
turn off those game settings what do you
mean turn off the game settings I have
so much to learn guys this is I met I
met the limit I'm at the limit now I'm
asking you guys to show me what's going
on left corner arrow
oh that hops out I don't want that I
want to be inside of the camera and but
I want to change the focus lens settings
in cinema camera actor search details
you can search for focus okay so I guess
you can search with the Senate camera
actor selected search will go focus
focus method tracking is that auto focus
I cannot tell back in tracking manual
manual focus
smooth focus focus offset
underneath the lens settings focus
settings manual disable tracking do not
override
oh it's gonna track a certain element
okay actor to track let's try tracking
these foreground rocks this one right
here
boom
but it's not doing it huh I do not know
focus offset is that yeah I don't know I
have no idea
maybe I needed to select a different one
I feel like it's not updating oh the
high drop are okay yeah there we go
so the eyedropper is working nice
let's try moving the Sun round a light
source
to see FPS go to the upper left arrow on
the side of the perspective and look the
show FPS control shift H there we go on
our 25th second very nice
I really appreciate the help guys yeah
this is it
so I mean in review you download the
epic games launcher okay
you go to library you download the
latest version and you launch unreal
this is where your different scenes are
so let me open up my photo recreation
for you guys and show you where I'm at I
have a lot of work to do and a long way
to go to get this thing looking photo
real like that Australia video or like
rebirth you know that's definitely the
goal I'm gonna open a level and we'll go
I think it's the water test is where I'm
doing all this in and this is where I'm
at let me hide the floor so we got the
you know some mega scans rocks in here
definitely need work on these shadows
because it's just dark on the inside I
feel like I need some bounce light I got
a little water shader going on here that
I'm still working on this is just the
ripples it still needs like refraction
and reflection and depth opacity and
everything and I've been having a hard
time with the landscape so this
landscape here is actually created in
cinema 4d and brought in as an FBX same
as this guy this little totem this is
imported from yeah it's it's an FBX
imported from cinema 4d right here then
you can take out the fog going and
everything but yeah it's it's it's not
there hopefully we can all look back on
this video and see hey this progress has
been made hopefully but yeah that's
about all I got for you guys thank you
for joining me on this intro this little
setup and Unreal Engine I hope you guys
download the program and can get excited
about all the cool stuff you can do with
that rebirth trailer and the Australia
thing I'll link that stuff down in the
description as well
you